esta vez por aquí tenemos algunos ácidos
fuertes los cuales se ioniza al cien por
ciento en una solución
hcl o cuatro este es ácido per clori co
h cl es ácido clorhídrico h
br es ácido brom hídrico y h y es ácido
clorhídrico h2so4 es ácido sulfúrico y
hn o 3 es ácido nítrico
por cierto vamos a trabajar con él la
ciudad nítrico y tenemos que resolver
este problema dice calcula el ph de una
solución de hn o 3 de ácido nítrico a
0.0 30 molar recuerda que como el ácido
nítrico es un ácido fuerte entonces se
ioniza al cien por ciento en una
solución y entonces lo que tenemos es lo
siguiente hn o tres más
h2o bueno el ácido nítrico va a donar un
protón al agua y entonces el agua va a
aceptar ese protocolo que el agua se va
a volver
h3
más positivo h 3 o más positivo o el ión
hidronew y si el hn o 3 pierde un protón
entonces nos quedamos simplemente con n
o tres negativo o nitrato y como el
ácido nítrico es un ácido fuerte
entonces tenemos aquí un 100% de
ionización es decir todo pasará a hacer
nuestros productos así que si en este
caso tenemos una concentración de 0.0 30
molar entonces también tenemos la misma
concentración de iones de hidrógeno está
concentración va a ser cero punto 0 30
molar esto porque estamos trabajando con
un ácido fuerte y si entonces nos piden
el ph y queremos calcularlo todo lo que
tenemos que hacer es meterlo en nuestra
definición de ph
h era exactamente lo mismo que el menos
logaritmo de la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno de h3 o
y bueno si ya tenemos esta concentración
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
sustituir esta cantidad justo aquí y
entonces me va a quedar que el pe h va a
ser exactamente lo mismo que el menos
logaritmo de bueno de 0.0 30 de 0.0 30
molar ok y habrá que sacar nuestra
calculadora para realizar esta operación
así que si traigo mi calculadora por acá
entonces vamos a hacer el menos
logaritmo de bueno esta cantidad 0 punto
0 30 y cierro paréntesis y esto me da de
respuesta 1.52 redondeando lo 1.52
recuerda que estamos tomando dos cifras
significativas así que en este caso me
ph va a ser igual
1.52 recuerda que tenemos dos cifras
significativas aquí y aquí también
tenemos dos cifras significativas
después de nuestro punto decimal ahora
en lugar de escribir esto de esta manera
que tengo aquí hay una versión un poco
más corta un poco más rápida de escribir
exactamente lo mismo podríamos escribir
que h no3 este de aquí lo que sucede con
el ácido nítrico es que se ironiza al
cien por ciento y por lo tanto me da h
más más
3 negativo y esta es nuestra versión más
corta va a escribir lo mismo que
teníamos aquí y si tú trabajas con esto
bueno entonces podemos decir que el ph
el p h sería exactamente lo mismo que el
menos el logaritmo d en esta ocasión la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno
ok ahora vamos a pasar a hablar de las
bases fuertes y para eso voy a bajar un
poco más la pantalla y quiero que
hablemos acerca de los hidróxidos
metálicos y aquí tenemos algunos dos
hidróxidos metálicos más comunes
hidróxido de sodio aquí tengo hidróxido
de potasio aquí hidróxido de calcio y
aquí hidróxido de magnesio así que
resolvamos nuestro problema dice calcula
el ph de una solución de hidróxido de
sodio a 0.20 molar así que escribamos lo
que pasa por aquí tengo hidróxido de
sodio y este se disocia en un 100%
porque es una base fuerte este se
disocia en un 100% en agua y así
obtenemos lo siguiente bueno el
hidróxido de sodio consiste en un en
positivo y en un o en negativo y por lo
tanto cuando se disocia nos va a quedar
un catión de sodio
a positivo y a esto le voy a agregar un
año de hidróxido
h negativo esto en agua ahora sí tenemos
una concentración de 0.20 molar de
hidróxido de sodio también vamos a tener
la misma concentración de hidróxido esta
concentración va a ser 0.20 molar y esto
porque el hidróxido de sodio es una base
fuerte y tenemos que ser disocia en un
100% y bueno si la concentración de
iones de hidróxido es 0.20 molar y
queremos el ph entonces una forma de
resolver esto es recordar la siguiente
ecuación que decía que la concentración
de iones de h3 o más de hidrógeno
esto que a su vez multiplicaba a la
concentración de iones de hidróxido esto
era igual
1.0 por 10 al menos 14 y ahora podemos
utilizar en esta concentración que
tenemos aquí y sustituirla justo aquí
estás de acuerdo y entonces nos va a
quedar que si decimos que x es la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno que
tenemos entonces vamos a tener que x por
esta concentración que es 0.20 esto nos
tiene que dar lo mismo que
punto 0 por 10 al menos 14 y si hacemos
las cuentas por aquí vamos a obtener que
x que por cierto recuerda es la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno
esto es importante esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que bueno la
división de este entre este y si hacemos
la división nos va a quedar 5 5.0 por 10
a la menos 14 y una vez que ya tenemos
esta concentración de itrón yo podemos
sacar el p h el p h es igual al menos
logaritmo de la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno que es justo esta que
tenemos aquí de 5.0 por 10 a la menos 14
así que para eso saquemos nuestra
calculadora y nos vamos a tomar el menos
logaritmo logaritmo de 5.0
10 elevado a la potencia menos 14 menos
14 y si cerramos paréntesis esto nos va
a quedar 13.30 entonces vamos a
escribirlo el p h en este caso va a ser
lo mismo que 13.30 ahora también existe
otra forma de resolver el mismo problema
y esto es cuando utilizamos la
concentración de hidróxido que ya
tendríamos y para eso podemos hallar
inmediatamente el pp o h cierto porque
el peo h lo habíamos definido como el
menos logaritmo de la concentración de
iones de hidróxido de h - y bueno esa
concentración ya la tenemos sabemos que
es 0.20 molar es la concentración que
vamos a sustituir justo aquí y entonces
encontrando el p
h esto va a ser lo mismo que el menos
logaritmo de bueno 0.2 lo cual es la
concentración de iones de hidróxido y si
sacamos nuestra calculadora déjame
jalarla para acá y voy a trabajar con el
menos logaritmo de punto 2 esto va a ser
redondeado 0.70 entonces lo voy a
escribir aquí nuestro p
h en este caso va a ser igual a 0.70 y
ahora para encontrar el p h lo único que
tenemos que hacer es recordar otra
fórmula una fórmula muy sencilla que nos
decía que el p h más el p
h esto nos tiene que dar siempre 14 y
por lo tanto en este caso si tenemos el
14 y sustituimos el peo h justo aquí
entonces nos quedaría 14 menos 0.7 lo
cual es 13.30 llegamos a la misma
respuesta y esto es obvio porque tenemos
dos formas de resolver el problema y
ambas formas son correctas no importa
cuál utilices
bueno pues terminemos con un ejercicio
más este de aquí el cual dice lo
siguiente calculan el ph de una solución
acuosa que contiene
punto 11 gramos de hidróxido de calcio
en un volumen total de 250 mililitros ok
tenemos hidróxido de calcio así que lo
voy a notar aquí vamos a empezar con sem
h está en paréntesis y aquí hay un 2 y
bueno este se va a disociar por completo
en una solución acuosa y veamos que
obtenemos de aquí vamos a obtener iones
de calcio en la solución se a dos más
más guiones de hidróxido
h negativo lo que quiero que veas aquí
es que si nosotros balanceamos esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí entonces por
cada dos de estos vamos a necesitar dos
de estos iones de hidróxido es decir que
por cada molt de hidróxido de calcio que
tenemos aquí por cada uno de estos que
esté disuelto en agua entonces vamos a
obtener dos moles de iones de hidróxido
ahora lo primero que sería muy bueno
saber es cuántos moles de hidróxido de
calcio tenemos recuerda que nos dan 0.11
gramos de hidróxido de calcio lo cual
voy a poner aquí tengo cero punto cero
punto 11 gramos de hidróxido de calcio y
una forma de hallar los moles que
tenemos es dividir esto entre la masa
molar del hidróxido de calcio lo cual es
74 gramos por mil 74
por cada uno
entonces si dividimos esto entre 74
gramos por mons 74 gramos por mol date
cuenta que los gramos con los gramos se
cancelan y habrá que hacer 0.11 entre 74
en la calculadora así que hagámoslo de
una vez
0.11 entre 74 y esto me dan vamos a
convertirlo 1.15 por 10 al menos 3 y si
recorremos el punto
0.00 15 entonces esto de aquí nos va a
quedar 0.00 15 y recuerda esto está dado
en moles esta es la cantidad de moles
que tenemos de nuestro hidróxido de
calcio es decir que si nosotros tenemos
esta cantidad de moles de hidróxido de
calcio
entonces cuantos muebles vamos a tener
de iones de hidróxido y bueno para eso
hay que recordar justo esa proporción de
1 a 2 por lo tanto vamos a tener el
doble de cantidad de moles es decir que
si a esta cantidad la multiplicamos por
2 esto nos va a quedar
1.00 30 moles y ahora estoy hablando de
la cantidad de moles de hidróxido de
hidróxido y bueno esta es la cantidad de
moles que nosotros tenemos de hidróxido
de calcio pero aquí ya tenemos la
cantidad de moles de hidróxido muy bien
ahora vamos a fijarnos en la
concentración de iones de hidróxido de
nuestra solución es justo lo que
queremos y la concentración va a ser la
cantidad de moles / litros es decir 2
litros de nuestra solución aquí tenemos
que nuestro volumen total es 250
mililitros así que vamos a convertirlo a
litros y para eso habrá que recorrer el
punto 1 2 3 veces y por lo tanto tenemos
0.25 litros así que para sacar la
concentración vamos a dividir esta
cantidad entre 0.25
litros y esto nos va a dar la
concentración de iones de hidróxido que
tenemos justo aquí y bueno esto va a ser
exactamente igual que am hagámoslo con
nuestra calculadora así que voy a traer
la calculadora para acá y voy a dividir
punto 0 030 esto en 3.250 y eso me va a
dar 3 entre 250 lo cual es 0.0 12 así
que lo voy a escribir esto es 0 punto 0
12 esta es la concentración de iones de
hidróxido esto es molar y ya casi
acabamos porque con esta concentración
nosotros podemos encontrar el ph está de
acuerdo usando cualquiera de los dos
caminos que vimos en el ejercicio
anterior podemos encontrar el p h así
que vamos a usar la siguiente ecuación
teníamos que la concentración de iones d
esta concentración que a su vez
multiplica a la concentración de iones
de hidróxido esto era igual a 1.0 por 10
elevado a la menos 14 recuerdas y bueno
ya tenemos esta concentración esta
concentración es 0.02 emular así que si
nosotros la tomamos y la sustituimos
justo por aquí entonces nos va a quedar
que x que multiplican a 0.0 12 esto es
lo mismo que 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 y
si esto lo hacemos en la calculadora
vamos a obtener que x que por cierto es
la concentración de iones de hidrógeno
esto nos va a quedar bien pues sacamos
lo esto nos va a quedar
1.0 vamos a hablar la calculadora por
acá por 10 elevado a la menos 14 ok voy
a cerrar paréntesis esto lo voy a
dividir entre 0.0 12 y me va a dar 8.30
y 38.3 por 10 a los 13 tomándonos dos
cifras significativas así que lo voy a
poner aquí esto va a ser lo mismo que
8.3 por 10 a la menos 13 y recuerda que
x se refiere a la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno lo que quiere decir que
ahora podemos encontrar el p h el p h va
a ser bueno pues el menos logaritmo de
esta concentración que tenemos aquí
estás de acuerdo de 8.3
10 a la menos 13 y si ahora sacamos
nuestra calculadora para hacer una
cuenta final entonces vamos a poder
resolver este problema nosotros queremos
el menos logaritmo de 8.3 esto por 10 a
la menos 13 y esto nos va a dar de
respuesta
12.12 punto 08 entonces si nosotros lo
escribimos aquí nuestro p h que es la
respuesta de este problema es 12.00
y ya con esto hemos terminado nuestro
problema y ojo este ph está en el rango
de una base lo que nos indica que el
hidróxido de calcio
a base